- [Voiceover] In the figure
above, the seven small circles,
which have equal radii,
and the large circle
are tangent at the indicated points.
If the area of the large circle is 36 pi,
so the area of the whole thing
right over here is 36 pi,
what is the area of one
of the small circles?
So let's think about how we could do this.
If we know the area of the large circle,
we could figure out the
radius of the large circle,
and if we know the radius
of the large circle,
we should be able to figure out the radius
of one of these smaller circles.
So let's do that.
So we know that area is
equal to pi r squared,
and so the area of the
larger circle is 36 pi.
So we know that 36 pi is
equal to pi r squared.
We could divide both sides by
pi, divide both sides by pi,
and we're left with the
radius of the larger circle,
I'll swap the two sides,
the radius of the larger
circle squared is equal to 36.
Now if you were just solving an equation,
r squared is equal to 36, you would get
that r is equal to plus or minus 6,
but we're talking about a length here,
so we only want to think about
the principal root of 36.
So we get the radius of
the larger circle is six.
Or another way to think about it
is the diameter of the larger
circle is going to be 12.
Diameter is twice the radius.
So if we were to start at
this point right over here
and go all the way across,
go all the way across,
that whole distance right there is 12.
So this distance right over here,
the diameter of the larger circle is 12.
Now the diameter of the
larger circle is 12,
what is going to be the diameter
of one of the smaller circles?
And they all have the same diameter.
Well, three of the diameters
of a smaller circle
are equal to the diameter
of the larger circle.
So each of these smaller
circles are going to have
one-third of the diameter
of the larger one.
So they're each going to
have a diameter of four.
Well, if they each have
a diameter of four,
that means that they each
have a radius of two.
So this distance right over here,
this distance right over here is two.
So now what is the area of
one of the small circles?
Well, the area is going to be
pi times its radius squared.
So pi times two squared,
which is equal to pi
times four, or four pi.
So the area of one of the smaller circles,
or area of one of the
small circles, is four pi.